for me it's like coming home I'm very
comfortable here I love being here
this is our sixth lifelong seminar the
Hillsdale lifelong learning seminars are
learning vacation all-inclusive you come
to campus and spend time with professors
and like-minded guests learning in depth
about Hillsdale College topics I am
getting so much more out of my education
here than I did in college
there's no saturation point to education
and as we get older it's important to
continue to learn if anybody had told me
a course in comparative economics be
fascinating I would say it's all really
it was one of the first ones we came to
I find out that we're gonna study
Shakespeare I said I know professor
Smith is one of my favorite people he's
one of my favorite professors
Shakespeare came to life for me an old
woman by listening to him I hate to say
it but he inspired me to download played
opens to my Kindle so I could read it
again when we came here we didn't know
anybody we don't look for people who
said we just took for two chairs doesn't
matter who's everyone we've met here
they are all following the same wall
comments they all love our country deep
they all appreciate freedoms that we had
as part of our birthright and we all
want to pass it on
generation it's very uplifting to know
that it's here that Hillsdale is here
and that they teach or they teach it
gives me hope for the future this is
something that I can't tell you about
you have to come here and see it to
believe
[Music]